in March of 2015 we announced that we
were going to transition all of the
elephants on our three Ringling Brothers
touring units to the Center for elephant
conservation so those 13 animals will
come and live here the reason it takes
three years as we need to determine do
we have enough water supply do we have
enough staff do we have enough barn
spaces we have a two year old elephant
and a 69 year old elephant so the
decisions we make today will have
decades of repercussions
it's a 200 acres working facility that
was designed to this day still is
specifically for the care of these
magnificent animals
a lot of the cities that we play in are
not allowing the tools that we use to
work with the elephants so it's just too
hard for a business to conduct itself
that way basically all it is is it's
just an extension of our hand there's a
point at one end and then it curves at
one end so I can like say Mysore come
here and I can pull her towards me with
part of it or I can say get over and
then I can push her over and everybody
is trained to use them properly so it's
just it's a very very good tool just
like using a collar and leash on a dog
and a bit and bridle on a horse since
1976
you can't import elephants or export
elephants from countries where they live
the best thing about our elephants here
they're never in danger from poachers
they're never as you can see going to go
hungry they don't have to walk 3040
miles a day to forage for food water so
we think that this is an ideal
environment to be an elephant well
everything that you see now in a
Ringling Brothers performance is a part
of their natural behaviour elephants do
stand on their heads I've seen it here
on many occasions I've seen them balance
on balls that they play with their
training will continue because there's
used to being around people and you have
to work with them and they have to be
used to people for us to be able to
continue the valuable research
you put two elephants in this section
three elephants to the other or regular
you have one one and two on the other
side most trains have at least two of
these cars if not more depending on
Rebellion's they have maybe there's like
rain seatbelts you can keep them
tethered if it isn't going through an
area with a lot of curves so that
obviously you don't want them because
they weigh enough that's why you would
have them in this way rather than this
way they can move around throughout
their area can we make sure we can clean
up behind them
refresh feed in front of them make sure
the ventilation if you look above you
we also pop up within doors all of this
can open
our primary goal is to ensure that the
Asian elephant does not go extinct and
also to make sure we have better care
and welfare for the Asian elephant by
using the animals here we're learning so
much from them whether it's our
physiology their reproduction their
endocrinology ehv is actually a very
fatal hemorrhagic disease and Asian
elephants so fortunately for us we have
a resource of so many elephants so what
it enables us to study whether why
certain elephants are more prone for
this disease or what kind of immunity
they have when they eventually come here
we're really excited because all 42
elephants will be here on one side and
many of them are younger females so that
way we can't either naturally breathe em
or be part of the artificial
insemination herd we've had 26 bursts so
far and these two females here Mysore is
69 she's our oldest and Sarah is 58 they
spent a lot of time on the circus when
they were younger and they're retired
here what our company would like to do
is just make it so that the Asian
elephant is existing in the Western
Hemisphere for everyone to see we want
our grandkids to be able to see an Asian
elephant
you